[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann für den
Sport einen schönen guten abendag von
mir und das sind die Nachrichtenthemen
dieses
freitags doppelte Botschaft vom
EU-Gipfel Ungarn blockiert neue
Milliardenhilfen für Kiev in der Ukraine
überwiegt die Freude über den Start von
Beitrittsverhandlungen Haftstrafe für
maskenmillionären die politikertochter
Andrea Tandler muss wegen
Steuerhinterziehung mehr als vier Jahre
ins
Gefängnis herausragendes
Mannschaftsergebnis Benedikt doll
gewinnt den biathlonsprint beim Weltcup
in Lenzer Haide drei weitere Deutsche
unter den Top
se fast z nach dem Angriff Russlands
haben 26 von 27 eumgliedern der Ukraine
die Hand gereicht sie haben
aufnahmeverhandlungen mit Kiev
beschlossen und weitere Gelder zugesagt
nur Ungarns Regierungschef Orban stellt
sich quer beschuldigt seine Partner in
der EU den Krieg verlängern zu wollen
der Bundeskanzler gibt sich trotzdem
zuversichtlich aus Brüssel Isabel
sch für den deutschen Bundeskanzler
endet der letzte EU-Gipfel in diesem
Jahr mit einer der Geschlossenheit in
Richtung Kiev und Moskau die Ukraine ist
aber nicht nur einen großen Schritt auf
ihrem Weg in die EU vorangekommen sie
kann auch unvermindert auf die
Unterstützung der Europäischen Union
bauen Putin setzt darauf dass die
Bereitschaft in unseren Ländern die
Ukraine zu unterstützen nachlassen wird
da ist er aber schief gewickelt doch
ganz so eindeutig ist diese
Geschlossenheit nicht die 50 Milliarden
Euro Finanzhilfe für die Ukraine konnte
der Gipfel nicht auf den Weg bringen
denn in Ungarn blockiert nicht zum
ersten Mal die Ungeduld der anderen
wächst es ist nun notwendig an möglichen
Alternativen zu arbeiten um auch dann
eine Lösung zu finden falls eine
Einigung mit 27 also einstimmig nicht
möglich
ist allerdings ist es einfacher
bestehende Instrumente zu nutzen wenn
wir neue Werkzeuge entwickeln müssen wir
unsere nationalen Parlamente befragen
das ist kompliziert in Demokratien
braucht so etwas Zeit aber die Ukrain
hat keine Zeit deshalb soll zunächst
versucht werden Viktor Orban doch noch
zum Einlenken zu bringen was er im
Gegenzug erwartet machte er heute in
einem TV-Interview ganz deutlich die
Freigabe aller EU-Gelder die wegen
Verstößen gegen die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
eingefroren
sind dies ist eine großartige
Gelegenheit um deutlich zu machen dass
wir erhalten müssen was uns rechtmäßig
zusteht nicht die Hälfte oder ein
Viertel sondern wir müssen das ganze
Geld bekommen wir fordern eine faire
Behandlung und das ist jetzt eine gute
Chance sie zu bekommen gut ein Drittel
der Gelder für Ungarn hatte die
EU-Kommission diese Woche bereits
freigegeben aber von Orban erpressen
lassen wolle man sich nicht heißt es
auch heute weiter in Brüssel
Ulf Röller in Brüssel was macht den
Erpressungsversuch aubn zu heikel na es
ist schon sehr sehr schwierig wenn ein
einzelnes Land eben wie Ungarn seine
Vetomacht missbraucht um die EU zu
erpressen damit sie mehr Geld bekommen
Ungarn hat das immer wieder gemacht war
dabei auch sehr erfolgreich und das
könnte dazu führen dass auch andere
Länder das nachmachen und dann hat die
EU ein wirkliches Problem im konkreten
Fall der Ukraine Finanzhilfen spielt das
Verhalten von Oran zwar eine Rolle aber
es ist nicht entscheidend im Januar wird
es ein weiteren EU-Gipfel dazu geben und
wenn Orban weiter bei seinem Nein bleibt
sagen die 26 anderen Regierungschefs
dann machen wir halt die Finanzhilfen
ne ohne Orban das geht das ist etwas
komplizierter und schwieriger aber man
ist fest entschlossen das zu machen und
insofern geht die Botschaft hier aus
Brüssel aus dass die Ukraine ihr Geld
auf alle Fälle bekommt egal wie sich
Orban verhält danke schön nach Brüssel
Ulf Röller war das ein Sieg der
motiviert inspiriert und stärkt mit
diesen Worten hat ukraines Präsident
selenski die Entscheidung der EU begrüßt
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit seinem Land
aufzunehmen die Ukraine ist nach
Russland der zweitgrößte Flächenstaat
Euro
36 Millionen Menschen leben jetzt noch
dort am 24 Februar 2022 wurde das Land
von Russland angegriffen vier Tage
später folgte der Antrag auf
Mitgliedschaft in der EU Tim Kröger mit
Reaktionen aus der
Ukraine vor einem Jahr mitten im Krieg
hat Ola pomosova einen mutigen Schritt
gewagt und ihre kleine Weinbar
aufgemacht die tagsüber ein Kaffee ist
sie möchte etwas aufbauen die EU
Beitrittsgespräche sein Fortschritt für
die Ukraine sagt
sie das sind coole Nachrichten das ist
eine super Richtung wenn es nach mir
geht würde ich immer den Weg in die
Europäische Union wählen noch aber sei
es ein langer Weg auf dem Maidan jenem
zentralenplatz in KI wo vor 10 Jahren
die proeuropäischen Proteste begannen
sind viele Menschen erleichtert dass die
EU Beitrittsverhandlungen aufgenommen
werden das ist sehr wichtig das ist
einearke mentale unterstüung hoffen sehr
darauf dass Europa uns nicht allein
lässt das ist eine Inspiration und macht
Hoffnung auf eine bessere
Zukunft wenn diese Entscheidung nicht
getroffen worden wäre dann wäre es ein
offenes und klares Zeichen an Russland
gewesen dass es ungestraft tun kann was
es möchte noch aber muss die Ukraine
hoffen dass die 50 Milliarden Euro an EU
Finanzhilfen freigegeben werden die
wichtig sind damit das Land weiter
funktionieren
kann es geht um die Gehälter in der
öffentlichen Verwaltung der Ärzte der
Lehrer und um die Gehälter in den
sozialen
Einrichtungen die EU Beitrittsgespräche
machen offenbar vielen in der Ukraine
Hoffnung in einer Gegenwart in der durch
den russischen Angriffskrieg Tod Leid
und Trauer allgegenwärtig
sind die Haltung zur Ukraine ist auch
Thema im aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer
Matthias fornof ist hier guten Abend
guten Abend wollen die Befragten die
Ukraine als EU-Mitglied ja da sehen wir
schon seit Monaten ein relativ stabiles
Bild mit einer Mehrheit für den
EU-Beitritt
52% sind dafür die Ukraine in den
nächsten Jahren in die EU aufzunehmen
41% wollen das nicht interessant ist
auch dass der Anteil derer die die
Ukraine noch stärker militärisch
unterstützen wollen gestiegen ist jetzt
zur Bundesregierung die hat gar keinen
Boden gut machen können ganz im
Gegenteil ne ja Kanzler Olaf Scholz
stürzt auf seine schlechteste Bewertung
im Politbarometer und auch die
Bundesregierung wird negativ gesehen die
Ampel macht ihre Arbeit schlecht sagen
68% trotzdem wird sie bis zur regulären
Wahl 2025 durchhalten erwartet eine
Mehrheit von
57%. wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre
kenme die SPD auf 14 % -1 Union 32% +1
grüne 14 -1 FDP 5 AFD 22 linke 4 alle
unverändert Freie Wähler 3%. das würde
reichen für CDU CSU mit grünen oder SPD
lass uns noch kurz über die
Befindlichkeit der Befragten sprechen
wie haben die dieses Krisenjahr erlebt
ja trotz aller Krisen persönlich war es
für die meisten ein gutes Jahr 66% sagen
das war für mich persönlich ein gutes
Jahr und und auch der Ausblick auf 2024
ist eher optimistisch 28% erwarten dass
es für sie besser wird
28% glauben es bleibt gleich und nur 13%
fürchten dass es schlechter wird ja
bleiben wir optimistisch vielen Dank
Matthias fornof und das ausführliche ZDF
Politbarometer mit Matthias vnof gibt's
dann heute abend ab 22 Uhr im heute
journal oder schon jetzt online auf ZDF
heute und in App dort haben wir alle
Daten zum Durchklicken auch die Top 10
der wichtigsten Politiker und
Politikerinnen wie die Ampel das
Haushaltsloch im nächsten Jahr schließen
will darauf hat sie sich vorgestern
geeinigt heute im Bundestag ging es um
das noch laufende Jahr und da setzte die
Regierungsmehrheit die Schuldenbremse
ein weiteres Mal aus für Geld das
bereits ausgegeben wurde z.B für die Gas
und strompreisbremse wurde ein
agshaushalt verabschiedet die geplante
Neuverschuldung liegt jetzt bei fast 71
Milliarden
EUR auch der Bundesrat hat dem
Nachtragshaushalt zugestimmt sowie dem
höheren CO2 Preis außerdem wurde
beschlossen dass die Kommunen künftig
wärmepläne erarbeiten müssen auf den Weg
gebracht hat die Länderkammer auch dies
Georgien und Moldau gelten künftig in
Asylverfahren als sichere
Herkunftsstaaten in Nahen Osten die EU
und westliche Staaten haben Israel in
einer gemeinsamen Erklärung aufgerufen
gegen Gewalttaten von Siedlern im
Westjordanland vorzugehen zu den
Unterzeichnern gehören etwa
Großbritannien Frankreich Kanada und
Australien Deutschland und die USA sind
nicht dabei im Gazastreifen fordern die
schweren Kämpfe immer mehr Opfer auf
beiden Seiten Susanne Santina
berichtet Trauer um einen gefallenen
israelischen Offizier erdigungen sind
zum Alltag in Israel geworden bislang
wurden rund 450 Armeeangehörige getötet
zuletzt wurden die Leichen dieser zwei
19-Jährigen israelischen Soldaten und
eines 28-Jährigen Franzosen geborgen er
war beim Nova Festival am 7 Oktober
entführt
worden in Gaza gehen die israelische
Bodenoffensive und Luftangriffe mit
unveränderter Härte weiter der
amerikanische Sicherheitsberater
Sullivan traf sich heute in ramala mit
Präsident abas und wiederholte worum er
gestern den israelischen Premier
Netanyahu gebeten hatte statt der
breiten Bodenoffensive gezielte
militärische
Operationen unser gemeinsames Ziel ist
sicherzustellen dass die Hamas nie
wieder zu einer Bedrohung für Israel
wird während wir die Gefahr für
Zivilisten verringern und mehr
humanitäre Hilfe in Gaza ermöglichen
wollen in Raffa im südlichen Gaza gibt
es mehrere Tote durch einen israelischen
Luftangriff gestern noch heute versuchen
Anwohner sie zu bergen
es sind alles Zivilisten unschuldige
Kinder wir suchen seit gestern
Nachmittag nach
ih während die von der Hamas
kontrollierte Gesundheitsbehörde von
mehr als 18 000 Menschen spricht die in
Gaza getötet wurden macht sie keine
Angaben darüber wie viele davon Hamas
Terroristen sind die israelischen
Sicherheitsbehörden zeigen diese Bilder
mehr als 70 Terroristen hätten sich
gestern gestellt und ihre Waffen
abgegeben die sie in einem kinderkrank
Haus gelagert hätten und in Israel immer
wieder raketenalarm heute Nachmittag in
Jerusalem auch die Menschen hier spüren
fast täglich dass ihr Land im Krieg
ist seit Beginn des gazakriegs häufen
sich Attacken auf Handelsschiffe im
Roten Meer heute gab es wiederangriffe
auch auf ein Schiff der deutschen
räderei
hapaklut der Frachter war in der
Meerenge zwischen dem Roten Meer und dem
Golf von Aden unterwegs die Geschosse
kamen aus dem Jemen die dort en hui
Rebellen hatten angekündigt aus
Solidarität mit der Hamas Schiffe mit
Verbindung zu Israel anzugreifen
habgleut und die dänische räderei mersk
setzen ihre Fahrten durchs Rote Meer
aus die Mission der Bundeswehr im
westafrikanischen Mali ist beendet 10
Jahre lang hatte sie sich an der
UN-Mission in dem Land beteiligt die
letzten Einheiten sind heute nach
Deutschland zurückgekehrt und wurden im
niedersächsischen wunsdorf von
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
empfangen zuletzt waren 142 deutsche
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in Mali im
Einsatz nach einem Militärputsch im Jahr
2020 hatten die neuen Machthaber den
Abzug der Soldaten
verlangt die AFD Vorsitzende Weidel muss
sich mit Plagiatsvorwürfen
auseinandersetzen nach Informationen der
Süddeutschen Zeitung prüft die
Universität bei reut ihre Doktorarbeit
aus dem Jahr 2011 zwei plagiatsucher
hatten Weidel in einem Gutachten das
auch dem ZDF vorliegt vorgeworfen fremde
Quellen übernommen und dies nicht
ausreichend gekennzeichnet zu haben
Weidel weiß das als abwegig
zurück wer erinnert sich nicht zu Beginn
der coronapandemie gab es überall einen
echten Mangel etwa an
coronamasken wer damals Schutzkleidung
vermitteln konnte und gute Beziehungen
hatte verdiente schnell sehr viel Geld
wie Andrea Tandler ihr Vater war mal CSU
Finanzminister in Bayern
48,3 Millionen Euro Provisionen erhielt
die 51-Jährige die hat sie allerdings
nicht ordnungsgemäß versteuert und wurde
dafür jetzt verurteilt zu 4er Jahren und
5 Monaten Haft Peter
aumeierer in Handschellen wird Andrea
Tandler heute zur Urteilsverkündung
vorgeführt in der coronakrise hatte die
Tochter des früheren CSU poliitikers
Gerold Tandler ihre politischen Kontakte
und ihren Namen dazu genutzt den Verkauf
von Schutzmasken an bundesl und dem Bund
zu vermitteln und sie hatte dafür
Provisionen in Höhe von knapp 50
Millionen Euro bekommen dieses Geld aber
nicht ordnungsgemäß versteuert es ging
allein um die Frage ob Steuern
hinterzogen wurden insoweit hat die
Kammer die Frage mit ja beantwortet und
hat darüber hinaus auch festgehalten
dass eine vermeintlich edle Gesinnung
die hinter diesen Geschäften
möglicherweise stand keine
Rechtfertigungsgrund dafür ist
anschließend Steuern zu hinterziehen in
ihrer Urteilsbegründung wies die
Richterin darauf hin dass private
Kontakte zur strauochter und
euabgeordneten Monika holmeier die
Vermittlung von Masken überhaupt erst
möglich gemacht habe Tandler habe ihr
gegenüber so getan als wollte sie damit
nur etwas Gutes tun er spät im Verfahren
räumte Andrea Tandler Fehler ein und
machte so den Weg frei für eine
Verständigung zwischen Gericht und
Verteidigung sie hat sich mehrfach für
die angeklagten Taten entschuldigt und
sie hat die Initiative dazu ergriffen
dass die Steuern komplett bezahlt
wordden nach 11 Monaten
Untersuchungshaft durfte Tandler heute
das Gericht unter strengen Auflagen
verlassen sie ist erkrankt die mejähigge
Haftstrafe wird sie nach ihrer Genesung
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
antreten viel Regen und schmelzender
Schnee lassen die Pegelstände vieler
Flüsse steigen während sich die
Hochwasserlage in Bayern und
Niedersachsen wieder entspannt ist das
Winterhochwasser jetzt im Rhein
angekommen im Mittelrheintal vor Koblenz
wird der höchste Pegelstand Morgen
erwartet schon jetzt sind einige
Uferbereiche überschwemmt experten
erwarten ein Hochwasser wie es alle 5
bis 10 Jahre
vorkommt jetzt zum Wintersport
Hochstimmung im deutschen Biathlon Team
Norbert schon der dritte Saison Sieg
dank einer erneuten Superleistung von
Benedikt doll diesmal im Sprint beim
Weltcup in Lenzerheide sein ärgster
Konkurrent aus Norwegen Johannes Tines
Bö zweiter ja und mit Philip na ein
weiterer Deutscher auf dem
Podest wenn dieen erfüll werden dann
ergeben sich solche Bilder Benedik doll
und sein erster Weltcupsieg in diesem
Winter die Basis ein fehlerfreies
schießen insgesamt ze Treffer war
wirklich ein geiles Gefühl beim Schießen
und auf der Strecke hat mir glaube ich
richtig richtig gute sch also großes Lob
an die Techniker im Ziel muss Benedikt
doll bange Minuten des Wartens ertragen
denn der Norweger Johannes tinis B kann
ih noch vom Spitzenrang verdrängen die
letzten Meter von Bö er schafft es nicht
bened dowi
n FR und dr
pH ein fantastisches deutsches
Mannschaftsergebnis ergänzen Philip Horn
auf vi und Johannes Kü als
se ja und auch sie war heute erfolgreich
Lisa buckwitz die oberhoferin feiert dem
olympischen Eiskanal von insburg eless
ihren insgesamt zweiten Weltcupsieg im
monobob so richtig
begriffen hat sie ihren Sieg im Ziel
noch nicht nach dem ersten Durchgang
schon in Führung fährt Lisa buckwitz im
zweiten Lauf ihren Vorsprung souverän
ins Ziel mit der neuter Laufbestzeit
meine Ziele sind top 3 im Gesamtweltcup
und natürlich in den Rennen so best wie
möglich mich zu platzieren mit
Weltmeisterin Laura nete schafft es eine
weitere deutsche als dritte aufs
Podest schwere Strafen nach
gewalttätigem
schiedsrichterangriff kotcher Präsident
des Erstligisten Ankara güi wurde vom
türkischen Fußballverband lebenslang
gesperrt zudem werden fünf Heimspiele
vor leeren räen
stattfinden das dfbteam wird sich den
Feinschliff für die heimem in Thüringen
holen und bezieht ihr Trainingslager vom
26 bis zum 30 mai in Blankenheim damit
soll der Osten Deutschlands besser ins
Turnier einbezogen werden und danach
geht's nach herzogen AA auch vor den
beiden letztten
testpielen mehr dazu morgen vom
Bundestrainer höchstpersönlich nsmann
ist Gast bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr Thüringen und Franken
wird gestärkt finde ich gut und am
Wochenende fällt kaum noch Regen Details
hat gleich christerben um 22 Uhr freut
sich Anne Gellinek auf sie im
heutejournal danke für Ihr Interesse
alles Gute ihnen und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend seit langem etabliert sich
mal wieder ein stabiles Hoch über
Mitteleuropa und das bringt uns ein
recht trockenes drittes
Adventswochenende und recht milde Luft
an seinem Nordrand deswegen sinken die
Temperaturen heute Nacht im Norden auch
nur auf 5 bis 3° im Süden wird es kühler
bei 3 bis -4° es fällt auch noch etwas
Schnee am erdzgebirge oder an den den
Alpen das lässt in der Nacht aber nach
im Norden gibt es viele Wolken und der
Wind aus westlichen Richtungen frischt
schon mal auf im Südwesten gibt es
Auflockerungen da bildet sich dann aber
in der Früh dicht der Nebel und der
bleibt auch noch C am Samstag Vormittag
vor allem in den Flussniederungen auf
den Bergen gibt's morgen im Südwesten
schon viel Sonne im Norden halten sich
aber dichte Wolken es nieselt allerdings
höchstens mal etwas draus und der Wind
wird noch lebhafter mit starken Böhen an
der Küste und er führt auch weiter die
milde Luft heran morgen werden auf den
Ostfriesischen Inseln 9° erreicht im
Dauernebel und in höheren Lagen sind es
3° und auch in den nächsten Tagen bleibt
es recht mild es bleibt aber auch bei
diesem Unterschied im Norden windig
viele Wolken und auch mal etwas Regen im
Süden eher windschwach und Sonne wenn
der Nebel nicht dazwischenfunkt
tschüss